this is the Thames Estuary it's busy
shipping lane carrying everything from
small pleasure boats to massive
container ships between the London Docks
and the English Channel overhead is an
approach path for some of London's air
traffic but right there in the middle of
the estuary two miles offshore there are
1,400 tons of unexploded bombs in 1944
the SS Richard Montgomery was
transporting munitions for the US Air
Force
she was moored here for the night and a
combination of bad weather and bad
decisions when she ran aground on the
sand bank out there the weight of the
bombs broke the ship in two and it's
been sitting there ever since as the
tide digs a little crater around it some
of its cargo was cleared away but not
enough if the worst happens it would be
one of the largest non-nuclear
explosions in history seriously as a
comparison the Russian army has tested
something nicknamed the father of all
bombs which is the equivalent of 44 tons
of TNT this boat has 30 times that
there's an exclusion zone around it of
course marked out and listed on charts
occasionally some jackass will paddle up
to the masts and pose for a photo but
let's be honest if years of storms and
shifting sands haven't set it off that
probably won't either
so what are the risks well no one's
entirely sure that's the problem no one
knows what the conditions inside the
ship are and there's no research on what
sea water does to bombs over more than
half a century they should be fine
they're in clear cold water and while
the TNT itself doesn't degrade its fuses
will have worn away which would make it
safe if it weren't for the two and a
half thousand cluster bombs on the deck
above which could fall down on it and
which might have a slight tendency to
degrade and explode even though they're
not armed possibly depending on who you
believe so should something be done the
Coast Guard along with the receiver of
wreck the wonderfully titled British
civil servant in charge of this sort of
thing they publish regular reports on
the ship based on sonar and laser scans
and occasional di't the consensus view
is that it's safe but steadily degrading
as tide and time take the toll it's
probably fine to do nothing and trying
to clear it moving all that volatile
material well that could be much
it's greater risk to life let alone an
enormous expense and if it did go up
perhaps the water would contain both the
explosion but no uncertain there are
some extremely vocal people most of whom
live near the thing who say the risk of
leaving it is too great
the worst-case scenario is that suddenly
there's one nudge by a wave in the wrong
place at the wrong time and the
equivalent of a small nuclear bomb goes
off taking out the nearby towns and the
nearby liquid gas storage with first a
blast wave and then an actual wave this
ship isn't interesting just because of
what it contains it's interesting
because it's an unknown there are risky
things like this all over the world but
generally we can quantify them we can
say it's a one-in-a-million chance but
this is a risk that it's impossible to
put a number on or say anything other
than yes it's probably going to be fine
doing nothing is probably the right
thing to do and that's what the
government is going to do but we don't
know it's the right thing to do not for
sure the only way to know is to wait and
see and maybe buy some good insurance
small farms had reference Cooper um